I think it comes I think the the hunger
for a public life of larger meanings
comes from the fact that it's not easy
to create a life wholly within the terms
of individual self-interest or self
seeking or even a life of individual
individualism plus family life there is
I think a desire on the part of most
people especially those of us who are
fortunate to live in democratic
societies not just to cultivate our own
garden and to live a comfortable family
life but also to participate in shaping
the forces that govern our collective
life and to have a say a meaningful say
in the collective destiny and once we're
pitched in to a wider civic life once we
lift our gaze from our own private
pursuits and the well-being of our
families to the to the public or to the
to the common good then the values we
care about the hopes and aspirations we
have for the common good will
unavoidably follow now some political
philosophies say we should keep we
should try to cabin or bracket our
deepest moral and spiritual convictions
our vision of the best way to live a
life keep those in the private sphere
within our families within our churches
synagogues mosque and live a public life
that is cast in holy secular
Universalist
but I don't think that it's possible I
don't even think it's necessarily
desirable to insist that men and women
who care deeply about moral and
sometimes religious questions Park those
convictions at the side of the road
before entering the public sphere it's
not possible in many cases to decide
public questions public controversies
without growing on some substantive
moral convictions but I also think there
is I think it makes for an impoverished
public life